alors que la france traverse une période
d'élections présidentielles
ultrasensible a alors que le contexte
politique est explosif
alors que tous les français ont les yeux
rivés sur le destin de leur pays norman
sur une vidéo engagé extrêmement
polémique qui va tout changer
fort non c'est une vidéo sur les
serveurs dans les cafés et tout est
alors vous allez juger ça je sais pas
muté pour s'offrir hockey les serveurs
dans les restaurants ou les cafés
je les aime bien mais parfois sans s'en
rendre compte ils font des actions pas
très gentils comme par exemple quand le
serveur te place sur cette table bien
bancal ou pas mettre une petite cale un
paquet de merde pour la stabiliser ou
sur cette table que personne ne veut
juste devant les toilettes toi et moi se
fait maintenant six mois et est gérée
conscience piqué et giraschi venu merde
allez pas craquer une allumette ça a
explosé quand il donne cette corbeille
de pain bien bourrative qui fait que tu
as plus fin quand le plat arrive
l'addition s'il vous plaît quand tu as
attendu une heure additions et qui vient
sur la machine à carte
bah du coup tu peux repartir quand
essayé de l'appeler mais que tu as 0
charisme s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
madame s'il vous plaît est ce qu'on peut
vous donner du chiffre d'affaires s'il
vous plaît ou encore pour les remplir
ton verre pile au moment où tu raconte
un truc bien intime et s'est approché de
moi
elle avoue faire son chemisier et c'est
là que j'ai saisie je raconte à fait
alors moi j'ai absolument rien contre
les serveurs mais je déteste quand ils
veulent absolument te faire consommer et
puis à plus de l'eau s'il vous plaît à
dire une petite une grande bouteille
monsieur venant de l'eau normale
ok une vitesse c'est parti ou non une
carafe d'eau boîte simplement le cadeau
vitesse c'est parti non non de l'eau
gratuite du robinet qui peut les
toilettes
voilà ça que je veux simplement et
surtout plates ou alors les serveurs qui
font et le gigot super très bon choix
c'est vraiment une phrase commercial on
sait tous que le mec fera jamais et le
gigot si bien sûr moi perso je le trouve
vraiment dégueulasse je trouve que c'est
le moins bons plats de la carte chez
carré ce soir en tout cas en face qu'il
le fait plutôt bien donc après c'est ce
à quoi bon et puis évidemment comme tout
le monde je n'aime pas non plus les
serveurs désagréable pêche toi le plat
du jour c'est quoi le plat du jour sept
plats du jour c'est à dire c'est qu'il
ya un plat du jour et du chrono fromage
elle fromage du fromage fils de [ __ ]
madame je prends quoi merci à tous ne
sont pas battues casse alors mon
programme escalade comme tout le monde
comme un bon voire d'un du programme du
robinet j'imagine oui voila merci
quoique en même temps j'aime pas non
plus le serveur trop présent celui qui
va être polémique qui en fait tu deviens
un peu chiant tout se passe bien
oui merci vous avez besoin d'autre chose
non merci je veux être sûr que tout va
bien
oui tu es vraiment tout va bien ça va
pas les mieux limite à la fin le mec il
est comme ça quoi et le gouvernement ne
fait absolument rien à quoi c'est abusé
excuse moi je peux avoir la moutarde
serveurs ils sont hyper lent parmi les
serveurs vient toujours un qui fait
genre il a une mémoire de surdoué en
voulant retenir toute ta commande de
tête un tartare seulement avocats une
salade césar s'en trouveront un
croque-monsieur moi je vais prendre noté
ba1 ba2 en continu
moi je prends le steak tartare et puis
une grande bouteille de chardonnay super
[Musique]
j'ai tout oublié un comportement cette
pub est alors des céréales je sais pas
si vous avez déjà croisé ce serveur qui
fait plein de blagues pas marrante tout
le temps un peu comme moi on sait pas si
le mec et serveurs ou humoristes entre
qu'elle est plus fort en tant que
serveur ça c'est sûr donc le café avec
où s'entassent un steak lemay bleu ciel
ou double transept sait combien d'autres
maillots de 1000 euros ou tekken 5 euros
et je joue mon spectacle tous les
vendredis soirs à l'hippopotamus 1
pendant les happy hour voilà merci à
tous bonsoir moi c'est louis siquet bon
sinon à part ça j'ai rien contre les
serveurs je les aime bien même vraiment
je crois plutôt que c'est eux qui même
pas s'il vous plaît il est parti
d'ailleurs ça n'empêche pas parfois de
laisser un petit pourboire un os serveur
web chez un mec comme ça oui
par contre quand je fais ça j'aime tant
que personnes leurs marques j'aimerais
bien que cet acte de générosité soit pas
remarqué quand même regarder il a laissé
2 euros de pourboire
merci monsieur il manquait juste 2 euros
pour acheter un appartement et ma
famille sous un toit cet homme m'a sauvé
la vie nationale
en tout cas je dédicace cette vidéo à
tous les serveurs et serveuses du monde
qui font un métier faut le rappeler pas
toujours facile donc restés les mêmes on
vous kiffe comme ça et puis la prochaine
fois qu'on se croise on reste au bas ne
crachait pas dans mon assiette
svp bon là je vous cache pas qu'on ait
bientôt 9 millions d'abonnés sur la
chaîne youtube merci beaucoup
si on passe le cap des 9 millions avant
la prochaine vidéo vous savez quoi et
ben j'organise un petit resto et je vous
invite tous et vraiment je le faire ça
risque d'être folklorique
bonjour bonjour on est 9 millions alors
400000 burger et pour les poissons
vous luttez pas non je continue grâce à
la nouvelle mise à jour youtube quand
vous cliquez ici la source le bouton
depuis un téléphone ou un ordi ça fait
un truc nouveau
allez-y essayé cliquer avec votre doigt
en votre souris pour voilà pas mal non
plutôt cool hyper simple pour s'abonner
beaucoup plus instinctif donc merci
monsieur youtube et plus merci à vous je
vous aime énormément lâché un petit
penchant la super
revoir